[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Susan link
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen an diesem sehr
sommerlichen Sonntag schon dass Sie bei
uns sind hier ist der Presseclub und
wenn an diesem Sonntag
Bundestagswahlen wären dann läge die AFD
ziemlich gleich auf mit der
Kanzlerpartei der SPD und hätte mehr
Stimmen als die Grünen aktuelle Umfragen
sehen die AFD bei 18 bis 20 Prozent in
Ostdeutschland wäre sie nach den
Umfragen sogar stärkste Kraft Kanzler
Olaf Scholz spricht von schlechte
launeparteien die nun mal Konjunktur
haben in solchen Krisenzeiten Ampel und
Opposition schieben sich gegenseitig den
schwarzen Peter für diese Situation zu
aber warum ist die AFD aktuell
tatsächlich eine wählbare Alternative
für viele Menschen darüber wollen wir
heute sprechen unser Thema heute AFD im
Aufwind woher kommt der Höhenflug und
ich freue mich auf meine Gäste auf meine
Runde heute hier im Presseclub und sagt
herzlich willkommen anton ist bei uns
frei Journalistinnen und Reporterin bei
der Leipziger Volkszeitung außerdem in
unserer Runde Ulrich Reitz herzlich
Willkommen chefkorrespondent von FOCUS
Online Volker riesing ist bei uns Leiter
des Ressorts Berliner Republik bei
Cicero und ich begrüße die wdr-kollegin
Katja Riedel aus dem investigativresort
intensive Recherchen hat sie schon
gemacht zur AFD ein Buch über die Partei
geschrieben und ergänzt hier heute
unsere Runde herzlich willkommen und Sie
wissen wie immer streamen wir unsere
Sendung auf unseren Kanälen in den
sozialen Netzwerken dort können sie sich
sehr gerne beteiligen mit ihren Fragen
und ihrer Meinung zu unserem Thema heute
ja wie konnte es also dazu kommen dass
die AFD in Umfragen zur Zeit so gut da
steht es gibt einen der schon mal eine
klare Antwort darauf hat und das ist
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz wenn wir eine
handwerklich und politisch gut
arbeitende Regierung hätten dann lege
die AFD nicht bei 18 Prozent und das ist
die eigentliche Ursache über die wir
reden müssen nicht die
Opposition sondern die Regierung hat die
Verantwortung für die Stimmungslage im
Land und diese Regierung nährt die AFD
sehr Frau Ritschel hat der
Oppositionsführer März damit recht also
muss ich sagen dass ich über diese
Debatte ein bisschen überrascht bin weil
es klingt so als wäre die AFD jetzt
plötzlich wieder aufgetaucht dabei ist
sie eigentlich eine Partei die sich seit
Jahren verfestigt hat seit also vor zehn
Jahren besteht und auch in der Zeit in
der die CDU an der Macht war also wenn
man mal danach gehen würde muss man auch
die Regierungsarbeit von damals bewerten
und es ist nun einfach so dass es jetzt
aktuell natürlich eine große
Verunsicherung gibt in angesichts der
Krisen die wir einfach haben und die AFD
ist natürlich eine Partei die es schafft
eben genau diese Verunsicherung nicht
nur zu führen sondern auch sehr stark
für sich zu nutzen gleichwohl muss man
immer darauf gucken dass es eben auch
eine Partei ist die sich verfestigt hat
und zwar mitteilen rechtsextrem Milieu
mit Überzeugungen und mit Netzwerken die
sie praktisch geknüpft hat mit denen sie
auch arbeitet die auch einen Erfolg
mitbringen und wir sehen gerade in der
Diskussion ehrlicherweise diese Ohnmacht
von allen Parteien die eigentlich zehn
Jahren so nicht mehr sein sollte eben
alle sitzen da und alle reiben sich an
der AFD auf und geben sich gegenseitig
die Schuld und wir sind immer noch
offensichtlich kein Stück weiter wie man
mit dieser Partei eigentlich umzugehen
hat Herr Reiz ist es vielleicht doch die
Schwäche der Regierung die die AFD so
stark macht es ist die Schwäche der
Regierung und die in der Union
mittlerweile auch offen diskutierte
Schwäche von Friedrich Merz
Wähler die vielleicht sich erhofft haben
das ist neuen Kurs gibt nach dem Ende
der merkelzeit die sich hier einfach
enttäuscht fühlen ich habe mir noch mal
die Zahlen angeguckt weil so viel
geredet wird über die Aufstieg oder den
Boomer die Konjunktur der AFD die
ampelparteien am 14,5 % verloren im
Vergleich der letzten 10 Jahre und die
CDU hat im Bundesvergleich 5% gewonnen
das sind die Zahlen trotzdem ist es
natürlich so dass die Union eigentlich
stärker sein müsste eigentlich gab es
immer in Deutschland kommunizieren
Röhren vor allen Dingen zwischen den
beiden großen Parteien
findet im Moment nicht mehr statt und
hat seine Gründe die aber vielfältig
sind die versuchen wir heute in großen
Teilen zu beleuchten aber es ist in der
Tat sehr komplex ich würde gerne weil
sie die Zahlen gerade schon angesprochen
haben noch mal ein paar Werte aus dem
deutschland-trend dem aktuellen dazu
holen und da wurden die AFD potenziellen
afd-willer nämlich gefragt aus welchen
Gründen sie sich eigentlich für die
Partei entscheiden würden und da können
wir mal drauf schauen und da sagen
nämlich tatsächlich wenn wir die Grafik
mal kurz sehen zwei Drittel etwa der
Befragten dass sie von den anderen
Parteien enttäuscht sind Herr riesigen
ist es so einfach ist es einfach nur ein
Denkzettel über ja die Enttäuschung der
anderen Parteien na ja einfach ist es
natürlich nicht aber die AFD ist eine
entscheiden rechtsextreme wahrscheinlich
immer logische Parteien man kann hier
nicht trauen und das Interessante ist
dass ihre Umfrage Wähler sagen wir mal
das sind ja noch keine echten Wähler
ihre Umfrage Wähler das genauso sehen
sie trauen der AFD das Problem lösen gar
nicht zu sondern sie sind frustriert mit
der
gegenwärtigen politischen Lage nämlich
mit der Politik der Ampel die Grünen
treiben die Welle aus der Mitte heraus
das ist dramatisch und natürlich kann
man das auch vergleichen mit der
Regierungszeit von Angela Merkel als die
AFD schon mal bei 18 Prozent war aber so
ganz
[Musik]
unfähig ist es ja nicht so ganz
unmöglich ist es nicht die AFD
herunterzubringen denn sie war jetzt
seit 2018 nicht mehr so hoch und mit
guter Politik kann man die Leute auch
wieder in die Mitte gewinnen
den Verlauf der Entwicklung der Zahlen
auch für die AFD Katja Riedel das ist
ganz interessant finde ich wenn wir
davon so eine Enttäuschung reden und
wenn das so ein Gewicht hat in der
Entscheidung dann bekommt das so eine
Gefühlsebene also es ist nicht nur eine
reine Themen Diskussion ist das etwas
was immer eine größere Rolle spielen
wird auch die Gefühligkeit dieses
abgeholt werden für Menschen
das ist ganz sicher die AFD ist auch
eine Partei der Straße das darf man
nicht vergessen die ist auf der Straße
groß geworden es ist eine eher eine
Bewegung als eine Partei ist ja
eigentlich eher gar kein richtige Partei
sondern eine anti-partei eine Partei die
ja genau für diese Menschen sprechen
möchte die angeblich kein Gehör haben
das ist ja auch immer einfach erstmal
eine Behauptung so was zu sagen ne im
Moment wird sehr stark bedient eine
große Skepsis gegenüber staatlichen
Institutionen die die nur Menschen
erleben wenn Sie an der Kasse stehen und
für 100 € und einen halben Einkaufswagen
haben und ich mir einen ganzen wenn Sie
ein Pflegeplatz suchen Fachkräftemangel
erleben aller Orten und diese
Verunsicherung kann die AFD aktuell sehr
gut auffangen man darf aber nicht
vergessen dass sie dennoch ihre
Kernthemen hat also das Thema Migration
ist immer noch der einer der
entscheidenden Gründe warum man sich
dafür entscheidet die AFD wählen zu
wollen dass das täuscht auch ein
bisschen darüber weg wenn man jetzt sagt
der Grund wäre dass man enttäuscht sei
von den anderen Parteien das ist absolut
richtig wir haben auch in Deutschland
Trend eben genau danach gefragt also
Menschen die sagen ich würde die AFD
wählen welche Themen stehen dann da ganz
oben und da kann man das was sie gerade
gesagt haben sehr gut ablesen man sieht
einfach ganz oben ist das Thema
Migration und danach kommt schon das
große Thema Energiepolitik
Klima ich würde gern mal in diese beiden
Themen tatsächlich reingehen weil es
eben das ist was die was die Menschen
betrifft wir haben in dieser Woche einen
großen Schritt vermeintlich großen
Schritt getan in der EU-Außenpolitik es
gibt ein Kompromiss auf den sich die EU
Innenminister verständigt haben mehr
Kontrollen vor allem an die
EU-Außengrenzen ein Kompromiss der
wahrscheinlich erst im nächsten Jahr
überhaupt und vielleicht auch noch
abgeändert umgesetzt werden kann aber
kann der etwas bewegen wird ich sehe
schon im Kopf schütteln bei Ihnen Frau
Hitze ist das etwas wo man sagt dann
guck mal das ist doch die
Migrationspolitik die vielleicht auch
AFD weil er sich wünschen also wir sehen
jetzt genau das was auch ein bisschen
muss ich mal kurz noch schon mal den
Osten vorgreifen müssen in den 90er
Jahren gesehen haben dass es da auch
große Proteste gab gegen eine
Asylpolitik und dadurch hat sich auch
bundesweiten also Gesetzgebung geändert
das heißt Protest auf der Straße der
sich auch gegen Institutionen gewandtert
hat gelernt okay es verändern sich
Gesetze Wahlentscheidungen waren
trotzdem so dass wir eine starke
rechtsextreme Strömungen im Osten zum
Beispiel hatten und auch jetzt ist es
wieder die Hoffnung ich meine ich lebe
in Sachsen selber und wir sehen eben ein
Ministerpräsidenten der jetzt eben auch
seit Monaten und auch der Innenminister
bei uns das Thema sehr stark gesetzt hat
und März ist auch sehr stark übernommen
hat und man jetzt irgendwie das Gefühl
hat man muss sich genau diesen Menschen
jetzt annähern und der Rhetorik und
einerseits denke ich ja man muss es
ernst nehmen mit den Kommunen dass die
Kommunen sagen ich meine wir sehen das
bei uns auch im Umland Leipzig es ist
ein großes Problem wenn 400 Leute in
einem Containerdorf auf Munitionsdepot
oder Bundeswehr oder 100 Leute in ein
Dorf mit 400 Einwohnern gesetzt wenn da
gibt's jetzt erstmal das ist ein Problem
aber das dann so zu verkürzen nach dem
Motto wir schaffen das alles nicht mehr
wir können das nicht mehr ich merke halt
wir wollen es einfach grundsätzlich
nicht mehr wir wollen das gar nicht
irgendwie angehen das Thema das Problem
und das wird dann eher
also benutzen dann eben CDU-Politiker
teilweise um dann eben den Diskurs
aufzunehmen aber wenn sie mal
ehrlicherweise rumfahren und Leute
fragen die AFD früh gewählt haben 2019
bei der Landtagswahl in Sachsen ob sie
jetzt Herrn Kretschmer wählen würden
dann würde sagen nee weil der ist ja
Teil trotzdem immer noch einer großen
politischen Elite
Probleme zu lösen und
es da hilft es wenig zu sagen das ist
irgendwie eine rechte Rhetorik die
aufgegriffen wird von Kretschmann nein
es geht darum Probleme zu lesen es geht
gut also es geht um Probleme lösen und
es ist doch verblüffend dass die Grünen
sich aus der Mitte verabschieden und
einer Lena Berg offenbar gar nicht mehr
Bundeskanzler und werden will weil sie
diesen diesen Schritt jetzt zu einer
Problemlösung in Sachen Migration gar
nicht voll verteidigt sondern sie
kümmert sich nur noch um ihren eigenen
Kreis wenn diese Bundesregierung jetzt
diesen mühsamen Kompromiss
voll verteidigen würde wenn sie nicht
weinerlich sagen würde ach es tut uns so
weh und nur ihre eigenen Klientel
bespielen würde sondern sagen würde ja
wir gehen das jetzt anders ist unser
europäischer Weg Deutschland hat hier
eine Führungsrolle wir lösen jetzt das
Migrationsproblem wir begeben uns auf
dem Bild das Gegenteil ist der Fall und
versucht nur die eigene Leute zu
beruhigen wenn sie das machen würde
könnte sie dann auslösen dass eine
größere Zufriedenheit entsteht und das
migrationsthema auch in der Liste nach
unten rutscht wenn sich dann im Ergebnis
auch was tut könnte sie das natürlich
tun aber wenn wenn wenn aber hier eine
Politik nur noch sozusagen den jeweils
die eigenen den eigenen Umkreis bedient
und man den Eindruck hat dass die
Probleme nicht gelöst werden sollen dann
erzeugt das Frust also was kann man noch
mal kurz auf das gehen was da
beschlossen worden ist es beschlossen
worden wahrscheinlich noch verhandelt
jetzt ist es beschlossen worden von den
Innenminister dann kommt es demnächst in
europ deutschen Rat dann kommt es ins
Europäische Parlament es gibt
Nachverhandlungen die Grünen sind
gespalten in einem sagen wir mal
regierungstreuenflügel der sagt wir
müssen das alles machen sonst fällt
Europa auseinander was stimmt das ist
auch der große Punkt der sagen wir mal
der AFD ein Stück Wind aus den Segeln
nimmt weil wir haben 10 15 Jahre
Verhandlungen zu diesem Punkt ohne
Ergebnis gehabt jetzt haben wir zum
ersten Mal ein Ergebnis gehabt das ist
positiv und deswegen wirklich gut ich
habe mir aber nochmal die Zahlen
angeguckt
tut mir leid die deswegen ist das zweite
Ergebnis ist das in den Zahlen wird sich
nicht viel ändern weil nein
die großen Gruppen von Migranten die zu
uns kommen
die haben eine Anerkennungsquote von 90%
bei den Syrern von 83 Prozent bei den
Afghanen von 63 Prozent bei den somalys
und von
27,8% bei den Türken und so weiter das
sind 85 Prozent aller Asylwerber und das
heißt ja das ist ja auch Teil dieses
Kompromisses dass man sagt Menschen die
wenig Aussicht auf Asyl haben dann eben
an den Grenzen erstmal aufgehalten
werden das würde diese großen Gruppen
sind davon gar nicht betroffen das ist
ungefähr 85% sind gar nicht davon
betroffen also es hat sein gutes es ist
ein Anfang gemacht zum ersten Mal gibt
es eine europäische Einigung auf diesem
Thema was immer schwieriger wurde weil
es gibt in Europa auch immer mehr rechts
Rechte Regierungen in Polen in Ungarn in
Italien deswegen ist das immer schwerer
und es gibt die Angst vor rechten
Regierungen in Frankreich etwa so
deswegen der Kompromiss ist gut auf
Dauer wird er aber das Problem
sicherlich nicht lösen
das ist doch verblüffend bezüglich der
AFD was sagen was sie Bezug genommen
hatten sie sagten den wird ein Stück
weit der Wind aus dem Siegeln genommen
ich möchte das Bestreiten man sieht sehr
schön an den Reaktionen der AFD wie auch
funktioniert eigentlich könnten sie ja
sich jetzt auf die Schultern schlagen
und sagen wir haben jetzt mal was
erreicht eigentlich schwenkt jetzt die
Regierung und schwenken Staaten wie
Dänemark und Schweden die hier hohe
Anerkennung genießen auf unsere Linie
ein und wir sind eigentlich die die
schon immer gesagt haben das Gegenteil
ist aber passiert Frau Weidel hat sich
hingestellt und gefordert neue Wahlen
jetzt das ist die aktuelle Kampagne der
AFD die läuft und das geht alles nicht
weit genug also die AFD in ihrer Art und
Weise ist ja gar nicht an Sachpolitik
interessiert sie funktioniert in dem
Parlamenten auch nicht so sie entwickelt
einfach zudem was die jeweilige
Regierung macht und tut und wie sie
handelt die gegen Meinung und das ist
eben auch das Problem deshalb kann man
ja auch gar nicht weit kommen jeweils
was man sagt was man versucht wie man
sie versucht zu stellen es wird die
gegen mein
sie haben völlig Recht aber die
Alternative kann ja nicht sein zu sagen
wir lösen die Probleme nicht nein
auch uninteressant es geht um die
Umfrage Wähler und die sollen bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl
wieder zurück in die Mitte kommen und
dort verteilen vielleicht schauen wir
uns nochmal ja wir sind ein weiteres
Thema an was wir gerade schon gesehen
haben in der Grafik nämlich das Thema
Klima Energiepolitik etwas wenn wir
jetzt sagen Migrationspolitik sind wir
uns nicht ganz sicher was das überhaupt
bewegen wird was ich da tut ein großes
Thema ist ja die Klimapolitik und immer
wieder die Formulierung die
Begrifflichkeiten der großen ja bevor
Mundung
ist das nachvollziehbar oder warum
fühlen sich Menschen eigentlich bevor
man beschlüsseln müssen immer gefasst
werden Gesetze müssen gemacht werden
warum ist so etwas wie das
heizungsgesetz zum Beispiel etwas was
ein große Widerstand gegen Bevormundung
aus erstmal grundsätzlich geht es ja
darum dass wir gerade
riesenveränderungen vor uns haben also
diese Gesellschaft muss sich wenn wir
uns in irgendeiner Art und Weise
anpassen wollen an Herausforderungen wie
eine Klimakrise natürlich jetzt große
großen Wandel durchmachen und das ist
immer schwierig und das zu vermitteln
ist schwierig und also in der Natur
immer sie müssen halt Gesetze gemacht
werden die dementsprechend und das
bedeutet halt Menschen müssen sich
einschränken oder muss sich etwas ändern
und das massive Einschnitte was niemand
unterschätzen kann bei dem
heizungsgesetz kam es natürlich dazu
dass es in der Kommunikation bzw auch
wie es ursprünglich angedacht war Dinge
nicht mitgedacht wurden also eben das
ist auch ein soziale Entlastung gehen
muss eigentlich bei den Menschen dass
das auch klar kommuniziert werden muss
diese Bevormundung ist etwas natürlich
sitzt das Gefühl da was aber auch
betrieben wird ehrlicherweise seit
Jahren von der AFD oder von anderen
Gruppierungen dass der Staat eben
stärker eingreift das
auch bei der AFD die Kampagne keine
Bevormundung wir wollen nicht dass der
Staat hier uns bei uns ständig eingreift
und gesinnungspolitik und so weiter das
ist vorangetrieben wurden uns das muss
man aber sagen wir reden jetzt die
garnisse zu den Grünen die irgendwie die
Leute aus der Mitte herausholen wo ich
mal wieder sprechen würde weil ich
glaube in der Mitte müssen wir uns auch
mal ein bisschen ehrlich machen wenn der
wie immer reden gibt es einfach Menschen
die Überzeugungen haben zeigen ja auch
Studien die durchaus eine AFD Grund
Probleme kommen eben Rassismus oder
Demokratie Feindlichkeit das liegt jetzt
nicht alleine an den Grünen dass die da
vielleicht nicht mehr so sind wie wir
uns das vorstellen und das wurde eben
über Jahre einfach betrieben und in
Zeiten dieser Verunsicherung spielt es
einfach eine viel viel größere Rolle
dass man sagt ich will das einfach nicht
also dass diese dieses nicht verändern
wollen die Kommunikation gerade schon
angesprochen das ist ja ein Thema was
immer wieder angeführt wird die
Kommunikation
also die erste der erste Teil ja
antworten den finde ich richtig den
zweiten habe ich beim ersten Teil ist es
einfach so sie können ja sehen was im
Moment passiert Robert Habeck versucht
dieses Gesetz zu korrigieren das ist
sehr ungewöhnlich dass ein Minister sein
eigenes Gesetz korrigiert bevor es im
Parlament korrigiert werden kann Punkt 1
Punkt 2 es gibt mittlerweile eine Gruppe
in der SPD die sich um Kompromisse
bemüht und dieser Kompromissvorschlag
lautet nur noch die neuen Häuser müssen
diese Wärmepumpe haben und bei dem
bestandshäusern lassen wir uns Zeit
die SPD ich komme aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen das war 39 Jahre
spd-land die SPD will Volkspartei
bleiben und deswegen hat sie beschlossen
beim Klimaschutz auf die Bremse zu
treten und es etwas langsamer angehen zu
lassen so und deswegen die Korrektur am
heizungsgesetz weil wenn man den
klimaklebern oder sonstigen Gruppen
folgen würde dann könnte es ja gar nicht
schnell genug gehen die SPD fängt aber
ein Teil der SPD fängt aber jetzt an auf
die Bremse zu treten und das ist dieser
Vernunft geschuldet der ansetzen indem
man sie gesagt haben den Leuten geht es
zu schnell ist es zu hastig und es ist
handwerklich einfach schlecht gemacht
ich finde es lohnt sich in unserer Runde
jetzt auch mal einen Blick nach Erding
in Bayern da gab es gestern eine sehr
interessante Veranstaltung eine
Demonstration gegen das heizgesetz auch
mit Fokus auf die Grünen einen
Ministerpräsident Söder der aufgetreten
ist den ja mutmaßlichen
afd-anhängern in dieser Demonstration
zugerufen hat haut ihr doch ab es war
auch ein interessante Reaktion und
gleichzeitig aber auch ja eingeschlagen
hat in die Richtung wirklich die Grünen
ziemlich hart anzugehen Frau Riedel was
so eine Veranstaltung so eine
Kommunikation Wasser stattgefunden hat
wofür steht das was zeigt uns das
eigentlich ja den Landtagswahlen an den
Bayern in diesem Jahr haben wir dazu
sagen
sehr im Wahlkampf deshalb auch solche
Attacken irgendwie dass der Wolf oder
der Bär erlegt werden müssen also
populistische Forderungen populistische
Rhetorik und gestern hat er glaube ich
wirklich im großen Fehler gemacht indem
er auf diese Veranstaltung gegangen ist
er hat versucht sich an die Spitze einer
Bewegung zu stellen
die vor allem Anti grün war und vor
allem staatsfern war die hat ähm
Rhetorik bedient die wir auf vielen
anderen Veranstaltungen auf
Demonstration vor allem in
Ostdeutschland gesehen haben in den
vergangenen Jahren eigentlich seit der
corona-krise wo auch viele Zitate von
1989 immer wiederholt werden und
ins Gegenteil verdreht werden ganz der
Iris historischen Kerns beraubt werden
dieses da wollte er gestern hin und
wollte Punkten er ist aber als Vertreter
des Staates eigentlich wahrgenommen
worden als Ministerpräsident als jemand
der auch einer von denen da oben ist die
man ablehnt und da hat er glaube ich
jetzt gestern mal lernen müssen dass das
nicht so einfach ist aber ich fand auch
das Verhalten seines
Wirtschaftsministers Aiwanger da
wirklich sehr sehr bemerkenswert der
dort verholen gesagt hat die ähneln
dieser gaulischen wir holen uns unser
Land zurück jetzt müssen wir hier als
vernünftige dieses Land wieder
zurückholen also populistischer kann man
nicht argumentieren ähm ich halte das
sehr fatal weil es eben dieses Verhalten
das wäre eigentlich von der AFD kennen
ein Stück weit normalisiert wenn da ein
Ministerpräsident eines solch
bedeutenden Bundeslandes gemeinsam mit
den Wirtschaftsminister steht und sich
der Art äußert wir sehen auch das ist
ehrlicherweise über eine AFD hinaus
einfach innerhalb der Gesellschaft der
Verschiebung gibt wo es einfach sehr
viele Gruppierungen abseits eine AFD
Mittler gibt eben sind auch teilweise
ich erkenne zumindest auch von den
Freien Wählern nicht alle aber eben auch
teilweise das durchaus bedienen so diese
Art von Rhetoriken dass wir einfach
grundsätzlich sehen eben seit
corona-pandemie aber auch mit dem Krieg
das ist natürlich Strömungen gibt sehr
viel stärker Sahra Wagenknecht wenn sie
halt eben auch anzieht unter anderem das
ist der krasse Verschiebungen einfach
innerhalb der Gesellschaft gibt die sehr
stark auf Populismus
fand ich das mit dem Vokabular das
müssen wir noch mal erklären weil ich
muss mir oder ich tue mir jede
Bundestagsdebatte an wo Olaf Scholz eine
Rolle spielt ist mein Job so und das
spielt auch immer der AFD eine Rolle und
es gibt einen grundlegenden Unterschied
zwischen der Rhetorik von Söder gestern
und von eiwanger ich kenne den einfacher
lange ich habe den erlebt in Gilla Moos
das ist so ein Volksfest da stehen 15
Zelte rum und dann muss jeder
Spitzenpolitiker durch so ein volles
Zelt wo die Leute richtig viel Bier
getrunken haben da wird nur Politik
gemacht
und seit Jahren ist der Eimer der Star
auf dieser Veranstaltung der hat
rhetorisch gestern abgeräumt Söder haben
sie ausgepfiffen und Albaner haben sie
applaudiert warum der hat die Mitte
angesteuert der hat die Handwerksmeister
angesprochen der hat die Bäckereien
angesprochen der hat die Schnitzel
angesprochen die AFD
die begnügt sich nicht mit den
Bäckereien und den Schnitzel sondern
deren Rhetorik ist immer einen zu viel
sie ist immer völlig konnotiert nicht
nur bei höcke sondern auch bei anderen
es ist immer der Verkauf und das Ende
des Abendlandes das ist alwanger gerade
nicht passiert und deswegen muss man das
einfach sehen und ich weigere mich auch
sozusagen das zu verteufeln weil sagen
wir doch mal froh dass ist die Freien
Wähler in Bayern gibt weil
die sichernde bürgerliche Mehrheit ab
und die das keine Diskussion in Bayern
über die AFD gibt dass die Werte der AFD
weit schlechter sind in Bayern als in
anderen Bundesländern von Osten gar
nicht zu reden hat auch was zu tun mit
den Freien Wählern ist
die Mitte sind diejenigen die sozial in
der Mitte sind vom Einkommen her und
diejenigen die von der von der Gesinnung
her weder links noch rechtsradikal sind
okay also ich kann Ihnen sagen dass in
meinem Alltag und dem ich mich befindet
habe ich sehr viel mit Handwerksmeister
zu tun Herr krupala selber im
Bundesvorstand ist Handwerksmeister sehr
viele Spitzen Leute in diesem in dieser
Partei in den Bundesländern in einzelnen
Bundesländern sind genau eben aus diesem
Bereich das sind Handwerksmeister diesen
Bäckermeister und die haben teilweise
auch ein völkische Gesinnung also ich
finde es schwieriger
also ich finde das ist spaltet so ein
bisschen ab als könnte die Mitte nicht
auch teilweise
70 Polizei
nicht weiter und gesinnungspolizei führt
dazu dass die AFD gestärkt wird und er
weiß hat das sehr schön gesagt es gibt
Grenzen die die AFD immer überschreitet
und die Männer die sie wählen in
Umfragen wissen das auch selbst die
unterstützen die AFD ja gar nicht
ich glaube das ist falsch ist auch Karin
Prien Rassismus vorzuwerfen da wird an
diskursraum verengt wenn man schon
sozusagen
liberale cdu-politikerinnen beäugt dass
sie mal irgendeinen halbplatz falsch
gesagt haben liegt die Tonlage von
alberner auch nicht und im übrigen ist
es auch CSU und ich CDU man könnte sowas
in Düsseldorf oder in Münster kaum
machen die CDU ist hat eine große
Bandbreite und das
zeichnet sich aus das ist das ist da
auch
solche Bierzelt reden gibt und sich
darüber aufzuregen ist hilft nur der AFD
Frau hielt ich würde gerne einen Schritt
mal noch weitergehen wir haben jetzt
sehr viel quasi passiv über die AFD
gesprochen davon geredet wovon sie
profitiert merkt das auch in vielen
Definitionsfragen die da jetzt im Raum
stehen was macht sie denn richtig das
würde mich mal interessieren was ist
denn von der Partei aus richtig gemacht
im Moment was sie im Moment richtig
macht ist ja das kommt eigentlich daher
dass die AFD sehr lange eigentlich
innerlich zerrissen von lagerkämpfen war
und sich sehr sehr viel mit sich selbst
beschäftigt hat
es gab ein gemäßigteres Lager und einen
rechtsradikales Lager und dieser
Machtkampf ist eigentlich seit einem
Jahr zugunsten des rechtsradikalen
Lagers weitgehend entschieden und die
beschäftigen sich jetzt eigentlich
innerhalb intern schon wieder damit wer
jetzt zum Beispiel die europawahlplätze
bekommt aber es gibt diesen Machtkampf
gerade nicht zwischen den Lagern
streiten wenig sie beschäftigen sich
jetzt es gibt da viele Opportunisten die
sich dem dem rechtsradikalen Lager eben
aus diesem Gründen heraus ähm
unterwerfen und nach außen hin zeigen
sind die Geschlossenheit und sie sie
treiben Kampagnen sie reagieren sie
sehen was passiert und dann kommt schon
gleich der nächste Hashtag und die
nächste Social Media Kampagne es gibt
mittlerweile ein sehr ausgefeiltes ja
Umfeld das hat eben schon gesagt dazu
gehören auch die sogenannten
alternativen Medien die AFD nutzt in
vielen Parlamenten die Instrumente die
ihn in die Hand gegeben wurden sind wie
kleine Anfragen etc dazu um zum Beispiel
Zahlen zu generieren mit denen man dann
wunderbar polymisieren kann da kann man
das nächste Youtube-Video machen da kann
man Texttafeln machen man kann auch im
Parlament selber Reden halten wo man
dann diese Versatzstücke benutzt
inklusive Reaktion der anderen Parteien
die sind ja immer sehr wichtig und was
man auch sieht das Vorgehen was schon
von staatlicher Seite stattgefunden hat
nämlich dass das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz die Gesamtpartei
mittlerweile ja als Verdachtsfall
betrachtet das hat nicht dazu geführt
dass die Partei für die Wählerschaft
unattraktiver geworden ist im Gegenteil
spielt im Moment eigentlich in dem
Diskurs überhaupt keine Rolle und es
kommt auch sehr wenig Wasser sollten wir
uns durch diese 20 Prozent die die
teilweise jetzt haben und das Potenzial
ist ja sogar noch höher sagen ja bis zu
29% sie könnten sich sogar vorstellen in
solche Partei zu wählen da bekommt man
jetzt das Problem dass es sowas normales
hat
die sind da die sind als wären sie eine
normale Partei aber das sind sie eben
nicht ich würde gerne eine Frage von
Twitter mit reinnehmen die gekommen ist
und zwar in die an die Runde die Frage
warum wählt der angebliche so wird er
hier genannt Prozessfehler da nicht
einfach links
die Stille in der Runde ist auch schon
interessante Antwort darauf
der Linkspartei natürlich der AFD
geholfen hat und
jetzt die Auseinandersetzung über um
Frau Wagenknecht zeigen dass er ganz
deutlich ich fand einen Tweet von Frau
lösch gestern ganz interessant warum hat
er mit uns keiner geredet wir haben doch
die dingspartei eine Bundestag gebracht
also die drei direkt im Mandate und hier
hat sich eine die Linkspartei in ihrer
Führung abgekoppelt von dem was sie mal
war nämlich Protestparteien im Osten
auch Kümmerer Partei das ist vorbei und
da diese Kerbe in diese Nische kann auch
die AFD studieren lassen Sie uns doch
gerne oder nicht lassen Sie uns mal
bleiben ein Weg wir haben jetzt mal die
Themen ja beleuchtete die zum Erfolg der
AFD führen könnten jetzt gehen wir mal
ein bisschen die ostdeutschen
Bundesländer rein und haben uns da auch
eine Umfrage dazu geholt für vorsah die
im Moment im Netz auch viel diskutiert
wird deswegen schauen wir uns ja auch
mal an da kommt tatsächlich die AFD nach
aktuellen Umfragen auf zwei und 30%
ist das ein Stimmungsbild was sie
überrascht wahrscheinlich nicht nö
überhaupt nicht ich glaube man muss aber
immer sehen das haben wir bei der
letzten Bundestagswahl auch gesehen da
hat man ja da war es ja so dass in
Sachsen zum Beispiel die AFD sehr viele
Direktmandate gewonnen hat die hat sie
aber nicht gewonnen weil sie wahnsinnig
erfolgreich war sondern weil zum
Beispiel Parteien wie eine CDU extrem
schwach waren also sie hat also daraus
resultiert das andere Parteien schwach
sind und es ist einfach so dass das
Personal in den ostdeutschen
Bundesländern das ist nicht immer
überall gleich da gibt's schon
Unterschiede und auch den Wahlerfolge
gibt es Unterschiede aber es ist einfach
da es ist einfach sehr lange da es gibt
eine schwache Linkspartei ebend gilt
aber zum Beispiel für Thüringen wiederum
nicht da ist eben Bodo Ramelow als
Ministerpräsident jetzt irgendwie nicht
der klassische Linke ist aber eben gut
angekommen es ist sehr stark an die
Person geknüpft und ich glaube das
spielt eine wichtige Rolle weil es ist
grundsätzlich einfach so dass die
Bindung an Parteien in Ostdeutschland
einfach nicht so stark ist wie in
Westdeutschland die Leute wechseln sehr
viel stärker und deswegen ist das jetzt
nicht wirklich überraschend und es gibt
eben einfach seit über seit zehn Jahren
einfach diese Kontinuität und sehr viel
weiter wir haben einfach in Teilen von
Ostdeutschlands seit den 90er Jahren
Kontinuitäten gehabt wo eben eine NPD in
Sachsen sehr lange im Landtag saß das
heißt die Hemmschwelle für bestimmte
Aussagen oder für bestimmte Haltungen
ist relativ groß und es ist einfach so
dass eine AFD eben sehr gut anknüpfen
kann eben durch Handwerker krupala sitzt
halt in Görlitz bei den Leuten irgendwie
mit am Stammtisch der CDU hat es
teilweise versäumt sich solche Leute
eigentlich auch heranzuziehen wieder das
haben wir in Sachsen ganz stark gemerkt
dass jetzt versucht man
Nachwuchsprogramm aufzusetzen und merken
das wird Jahre dauern bis das greift
weil einfach also Sachsen oder auch
Thüringen oder andere aus Deutschland
das ist halt Provinz also das ist das
meine ich negativ aber das ist wir haben
nicht so viele groß steht das heißt da
gibt's auch ein deutlichen Unterschied
zwischen großen Unterschied es gibt ein
riesen Unterschied zwischen Leipzig und
Dresden es gibt einen Unterschied
zwischen Dresden Leipzig und der Provinz
es gibt ein riesen Unterschied zwischen
der Lausitz und
und Westsachsen zum Beispiel und das ist
einfach und wir sehen zum Beispiel in
der Lausitz CDU-Politiker die zum
Beispiel sehr nah an der AFD dran sind
ein Landrat der sich bei einer
corona-demonstration wie gesagt man kann
gegen Maßnahmen demonstrieren aber war
teilweise freie Sachsen stand Herr Hülse
mit oben dann plötzlich von Landratsamt
und dr da da damals noch
stellvertretende Landrat jetzt Landrat
hat sich daneben gestellt und zu den
Leuten gesprochen und das ist einfach
normal und werde das kritisiert ist
praktisch ja gesinnungspolizei wie sieht
das
sie haben sich auch damit beschäftigt
was welche Erfahrung ist das für sie
gewesen wie sehr ist der ist die AFD im
Alltag der Menschen dort angekommen
tatsächlich für MICH verblüffend zu
sehen weil unsere Recherchen wie
alltäglich ist geworden ist jeder
Freundlichkeit jeder Familienkreis war
30% kennt jeder irgendjemanden der auch
mal AFD gewählt hat oder damit das
überlegt
aber die wichtigste Erkenntnis ist eben
noch mal
die Unzufriedenheit mit der aktuellen
Politik ist so groß dass es die Leute
zur AFD treibt wir haben nicht auf
einmal 30 Prozent Nazis in neuen
Bundesländern und das ist wichtig zu
sehen und umso mehr man hier eine
Stigmatisierung der Wähler oder der
Umfrage Wähler macht umso gefährlicher
ist das und ich glaube es ist deswegen
auch richtig dass hier versucht wird
lösungsorientierte Politik zu machen und
wenn man sich das mal anschaut wie viel
Wähler die AFD auch z.B von der SPD
bekommt warum ist die SPD nicht mehr
Partei des kleinen Mannes wie man so
früher gesagt hat komische Ausdruck
eigentlich aber bei Partei der Straße
müsste die es bitte ja auch sein
viele viele Jahre tatsächlich gibt es
bei der SPD verblüffendes umdenken und
Frau Feser hat glaube ich da auf
europäischer Ebene soziale Schritt in
diese Richtung gemacht die Leute wir
haben euch verstanden wir lösen Probleme
aber wir sind da sprechen Sie
interessanten Punkt an auf der Politik
der Straße das ist ja auch das was oft
wahrgenommen wird dieses von oben die da
oben die in Berlin man kennt das ja
warum gelingt es denn Parteien wieder
SPD nicht Menschen egal ob jetzt in
Ostdeutschland aber eben auch da anders
anzusprechen strukturwandeln und
generationswandeln sie beides zusammen
nehmen also die SPD war früher eine
Partei der gehobenen Facharbeiter
sondern Nordrhein-Westfalen war das so
dass in den Quartieren wo die Arbeiter
gewohnt haben war der wer der
Betriebsratschef von Thyssen war doch
derjenige der den Ton an gab und in der
SPD auch der Vorsitzende vor Ort war das
heißt sie hatten vom Betrieb in das
sozialbiotop hatten sie eine Steuerung
auch über Werte übrigens
und wenn da einer wenn da ein Kind Mist
gemacht hat ein junger Mann Mist gemacht
hat dann war der Typ vor Ort und hat den
meinem Vater gesagt du musst auf deine
Kinder aufpassen und dieser dieser
Zusammenhänge die sind einfach weg weil
es diese große Industrien nicht mehr
gibt Nummer 1 Nummer 2 die SPD hat sich
einfach akademisiert ich werde nicht
vergessen
der Spruch von Sigmar Gabriel damals als
SPD-Chef der gesagt hat wir sind Opfer
des eigenen Erfolgs geworden also wir
haben immer für den eigenen Aufstieg
oder für den Aufstieg der Menschen das
aufstiegsversprechen war typisch
sozialdemokratisch jetzt sind sie alle
Akademiker und werden halt grün ein
bisschen platt aber so ungefähr ist das
und deswegen haben sie diejenigen die
ähm sagen wir mal noch ich habe mir mal
angeguckt wie früher die Kabinette waren
was da für Leute drin waren auch noch
Westfalen das waren gestandene Leute die
einen unglaublichen Schlag bei den
Leuten haben und das ist heute einfach
weg ein Blick aus spd-sicht man könnte
aber es einfach früher war es auch so
vor Jahren die gar nicht lange her sind
dass die CDU sehr stark war in
Ostdeutschland wo ist sie hin welche
Fehler hat sie gemacht
also eine CDU hat natürlich massive
Fehler gemacht auch in politischen
Entscheidungen also sie soll einfach so
dass zum Beispiel ist ein wahnsinnigen
also wenn wir jetzt mal konkret Sachsen
angucken im Bildungsbereich massive
Einschnitte gab und diesen Parteien das
eben auch stark angelastet wurde es hat
mit Personen wieder zu tun also wir
hatten in Sachsen König kurz gehabt also
kurban-kopf was ja auch ein bisschen
absurd ist ein westdeutscher der
Ministerpräsident wird und ostdeutsche
wählen ihn eben was nicht stark warum
selten vorkommt und genau herr Vogel und
genau der stand halt eben und der hat
halt war so der Landesvater gewesen und
das ist auch mit seinem abtritt sehr
stark erodiert und ja und dann
tatsächlich die parteienbindung und die
Zufriedenheit und was ich glaube ich
eben noch mal wichtig finde auch mit dem
Blick nach Berlin ähm es ist glaube ich
schon so dass lange auch unterschätzt
würde was eigentlich also wenn wir jetzt
auf Osten gucken was in Ostdeutschland
eigentlich passiert auch
gesellschaftlich und welche Ängste ist
eigentlich gibt also da sind wir bei dem
Thema
Krisen und der Versuch wieder was zu
ändern wir sehen einfach ganz stark dass
die Behaarung erfahrungskräfte im Osten
einfach sehr viel stärker sind weil die
Leute in den 90er Jahren so Erfahrungen
gemacht haben einer intensiven
Transformation die man sich kaum
vorstellen kann
nicht alle haben die gemacht aber es ist
so eine kollektive Erzählung und die
schafft zum Beispiel in einer AFD extrem
gut zu bündeln indem sie daraus ein
narrativ und ich finde es wichtig über
narrative auch mal zu sprechen noch mal
wie eine AFD nutzt denn die schafft es
zu sagen okay ihr habt diese Erfahrung
gemacht und ihr seid alle übrigens 89
auf die Straße gegangen ihr seid nicht
ängstlich ihr seid alle
Widerstandskämpfer und dafür was jetzt
passiert seid ihr nicht auf die Straße
gegangen da stehen vorne auf die
Abgeordnete aus dem Westen
erzählt den Leuten wie toll alle 89 auf
die Straße gegangen sind natürlich aber
dieses narrativ was umgekehrt auch
betrieben wird sozusagen
behaarungskräfte und wir müssen den
erstmal erklären dass jetzt noch mal
Wandel ist und so dass das hat auch
sowas paternalistisches es gibt auch
Leute die wollen einfach eine andere
Politik und da können sie na ja aber die
wollen unsere Politik sind die richtige
und dafür müssen wir die Überzeugung an
die wollen eine andere Migrationspolitik
sie wollen eine andere Klimapolitik sie
wollen auch mehr Beteiligung und das
muss man auch ernst nehmen man muss die
AFD bekämpfen aber nicht die Leute den
anderen heute machen mit Blick auf und
da würde ich gerne noch mal hinschauen
deswegen ein bisschen auch in die
Zukunft blicken und schauen wie kann man
reagieren wir haben zwar in diesem Jahr
auch noch Landtags waren aber in
Ostdeutschland sind sie eben in Sachsen
Thüringen und Brandenburg im kommenden
Jahr und es ist durchaus realistisch
dass die AFD da in einmal alle anderen
Bundesland stärkste Kraft werden könnte
Friedrich Merz hat sich in dieser Woche
ja noch mal geäußert er hatte schon mal
die Brandmauer Richtung AFD gezogen und
hat noch mal klar in dieser Woche
deutlich gemacht solange ich Parteichef
bin wird es keinerlei Zusammenarbeit mit
dieser Partei geben jetzt gibt es wir
schauen uns mal einen Tweet der Kollegen
vom MDR an ähm jemanden der das
vielleicht ein bisschen anders sieht und
es ist nicht der erste mit der Äußerung
nicht alle in der AFD sind Faschisten
unter anderem mit diesem Argument
plädiert der Bürgermeister von
Waltershausen Michael britzi von der CDU
Thüringen für eine Zusammenarbeit mit
der AFD auf kommunaler und Landesebene
in Sachfragen
Frau Riedel ist die Brandmauer damit in
Gefahr wird sie halten warum knüpft Herr
März da überhaupt sein Amt quasi dran
was er in dem Moment ja tut wenn er
sowas sagt weil er das muss weil es so
starke Kräfte in den betreffenden
Ländern gibt die das Hinterfragen die
eben sagen man könnte doch es die Frage
was wenn Herr Kretschmer das vielleicht
nicht überleben würde politischen
nächstes Jahr was wird denn dann
passieren wer kommt denn dann ist denn
da dahinter und welche Einstellung haben
diese Menschen ähm ich bin dennoch jetzt
der festen Überzeugung bis jetzt noch
dass wir keine Regierungsbeteiligung der
AFD in einem der Länder sehen werden
aber es wird sehr schwer sein eine
Regierungsfähigkeit herzustellen weil
sich ja oft Leute aus der CDU näher sind
mit dem Kollegen von der AFD z.B in
Migrationsfragen als mit einem Kollegen
von den Grünen mit dem man dann
koalieren muss also ich halte das
langfristig für ein großes Problem wenn
wir das nicht in Griff bekommen und ich
bin da was sie vorhin gesagt haben bei
ihnen man muss angehen man muss Lösungen
finden
seitens der anderen Parteien weil mit
der AFD wird man so keine Lösungen
kommen weil sie es eben gar nicht will
viel bedenklicher als das was dieser
eine Bürgermeister gesagt hat übrigens
wenn man das Interview ganz liest er hat
sich auf Landesebene ausgesprochen für
ein Bündnis mit der Linkspartei in
Thüringen
viel bedenklicher ist das was ähm
der FDP Mann
gesagt hat als er gesagt hat für mich
kommt eine Koalition mit den Grünen
nicht in Frage
wenn man sich die Gegenseite die
gegenwärtigen koalitionsmannschaft
anguckt was ist dann überhaupt noch
möglich nichts sondern das heißt also
er war ja mal gewählt und wurde dann
unter Umständen jedenfalls war ein
großes Skandal oder abgesetzt so und
jetzt ist er dran
als ein Oppositionspolitiker und sagt
mit den Grünen auf keinen Fall
so wenn sie drauf gucken ist eine andere
Koalition nicht möglich deswegen halte
ich das ehrlich gesagt in heutiger
Betrachtung für viel wesentlicher und
vielleicht auch für viel gefährlicher
oder bedenklicher als das was ein
Bürgermeister vor Ort denn eine ganz
andere Wahrnehmung hat da geht zum
Straßen und ob ich die verlängere und
eine Baustelle abbaue das ist eine
andere Nummer ich würde weil wir schon
wieder leider zum Ende kommen und
natürlich nicht alles abbilden können
würde eine mini-schutzrunde machen
einfach nur dass sie mir ein Stichwort
sagen was sie den jetzt demokratischen
Parteien raten würden welches Thema als
erstes angehen Frau Rätsel was wäre es
bei ihnen was sie raten sind tatsächlich
ist das erste Thema das wichtigste Thema
derzeit eine Klimakrise aber man muss
halt eine Affen Kommunikation finden und
eben Gesetzgebung die das alles mit
beruhigt sie berücksichtigt dass es eben
tatsächlich Tiefe Eingriffe sind und das
ist soziale Fragen sind die dort geklärt
werden müssen
Migration und ich wünsche mir dass die
Ampel auch alle voll diesen Kompromiss
mittragen sonst wird wieder nur Chaos
sein
Tempo raus besser erklären mehr auf die
Menschen zugehen und ihre Sorgen und
Nöte ernst nehmen
dann würde ich auch sagen würde da die
Sonderaufgabe noch Herrn Scholz zu
widmen wollen das was frau Merkel
eigentlich sehr gut vermocht hat in
Krisenzeiten dann doch so eine gewisse
Sicherheit und so eine Einigung zu
bringen dass das alle zu Hause geblieben
sind zum Beispiel in der corona-krise im
ersten Lockdown
das würde ich mir von Herrn Scholz
irgendwie auch mehr wünschen also mehr
Appelle auch an die Gefühle der Menschen
und ihre Sorgen machen ein kleines Paket
ja am Ende schnüren können als Auftrag
das war der Presseclub schon an diesem
Sonntag bei diesem Thema ist das klar
das ist so komplex dass wir gar nicht
alles schaffen konnten es geht im ersten
weiter mit dem europamagazin und sie
können bei uns bleiben bei WDR 5 und bei
Phoenix da gibt's Presseclub nachgefragt
Danke schön an meine Runde und danke für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit an diesem
Sommersonntag bis bald
[Musik]
und da sind wir zurück beim Presse
Klumpen nachgefragt wir haben heute das
Thema AFD im Aufwind woher kommt der
Höhenflug und da wollen wir natürlich
jetzt gerne weiter sprechen mit unseren
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern
ich nehme mal den Herrn ehrlich aus
Schmallenberg Bödefeld hallo ehrlich
guten Morgen wo treffen wir sie denn an
sagen Sie uns kurz wo das ist
im Sauerland bei Winterberg im Sauerland
herzlich willkommen in unserer Runde
Ihre Frage ja ich hätte
einen Ritt das heißt also dann wenn der
Jugendliche ein politisches Bewusstsein
entwickelt sagen wir ab dem 16
Lebensjahr dass dann in den
schulpolitische Bildung stattfindet um
ein Beispiel zu sagen im
Hochsauerlandkreis ein Berufsschüler der
300 Jahre zur Schule geht bekommt 40
Stunden politische Bildung
und ich
meine wenn wir den Bürger politisch
bilden dass er ja die Manipulation oder
die Idee nur Machenschaften der
politischen Parteien besser bewerten
kann dann ist das ein Rezept gegen
extreme politische Meinung ja bald meine
Meinung ich danke Ihnen für dieses
Rezept das werfe ich dir gleich mal mit
in die Runde ist ja dass man einfach
Kompetenzen schafft ist das eine Lösung
ist das eigentlich überhaupt ist das
überhaupt das Problem dass es keine
politischen Kompetenzen gibt also ich
finde das ist wunderbar Ersatz von ähm
Hörern
ich finde dazu gehört auch noch dass man
mehr Werbung für Engagement Parteien
machen sollte ich wundere mich und ich
sehe das bei meinen
Söhnen auch in der Schule also NGO sind
Engagement überall für bestimmte Ziele
wird wird gelobt und befördert aber
unsere Demokratie lebt von Parteien und
ich finde dass wir gerade in der
politischen Bildung auch sozusagen und
vielleicht auch im Journalismus das
verstärken sollte zu sagen ist Parteien
sind genau das womit wo politische
Willensbildung passiert und man kann
auch total das for future gehen oder
sonst wohin aber die Demokratie wie wir
sie haben funktioniert mitteilen
Kruse mit dazu nehmen aus Putlitz hallo
Herr Kruse habe ich sie jetzt warten Sie
jetzt habe ich sie ja guten Tag hallo
ja
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich da anfangen
soll das ging uns fast ähnlich und wir
haben gemerkt wir wussten auch nicht wo
wir enden sollen aber vielleicht haben
sie eine eine Frage die sie formulieren
können
Sie mir 30 Sekunden passen auf okay also
an dem Tag als die DDR BRD wurde
wussten die DDR Bürger ihr ihre
ddr-jacke abgeben und mussten plötzlich
BRD sein ich bin ein westdeutscher der
seit 20 Düsseldorfer der seit 20 Jahren
in Brandenburg und in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern lebt so
grundsätzlich ist es hat man den Leuten
gesagt wir leben in einer Demokratie und
das machen diese Menschen sie wählen
demokratisch eine Partei die Ihnen aus
der Seele spricht
wir haben nach der Wiedervereinigung
weder die gleichen Löhne für Frauen und
Männer die Renten oder was auch immer
angeglichen diese grundsätzlichen
Probleme sind nie angegangen worden und
nun hat die AFD es geschafft dass viele
Themen auf das Tableau kommen ohne die
AFD würden wir uns über viele Dinge
wahrscheinlich gar nicht unterhalten und
das ähm das schönste ist eigentlich ihr
Kampf gegen
AFD ist die beste Werbung für die AFD
weil sich die ganzen Probleme die wir
jetzt
Seiten haben ob es die Schulen sind ob
es die die Rentenpolitik die immer noch
in Ost und West aufgeteilt ist offen zu
Tage tritt diese Menschen sind auch
Demokraten sie sind aber in ihren
Grundsätzen anders erzogen worden hier
können nicht hingehen als westdeutsche
und so tun als jeder der die AFD wird
sich zum Nazi wird
plötzlich ein Anhänger also wir selber
lösen
würde gerne die Möglichkeit geben Frau
Ritsche zum Beispiel auf ihre Gedanken
zu antworten 30 Sekunden sind immer
schneller rum als man denkt danke Ihnen
für eine Minute gekauft
vielen Dank für ihre Meinung und wir
fragen mal nach bei Frau Rietschen was
sie zu ihren Gedanken sagt
mal kurz auseinander also ich bin auch
nicht der Meinung dass alle Faschisten
sind innerhalb der AFD trotzdem muss man
die Themen muss man ansprechen dass es
da Raum gibt tatsächlich tatsächlich
gibt es Probleme über die lange eben
nicht gesehen wurden also die
Unterschiede tatsächlich glaube ich auch
dass ein demokratisches Problem ist dass
man nicht darüber nachgedacht hat nach
der Wiedervereinigung wie man einen
demokratisches gemeinsames narrativ
finden kann also zum Beispiel die Frage
schreiben wir zusammen gemeinsam eine
Verfassung es wurden Gesetze dieser DDR
gab Thema Abtreibung haben wir einen
Rückschritt gemacht im Osten als eben
als es im BRD wurde dass man sich nicht
gemeinsam Gedanken gemacht hat über
einen demokratischen
ja an annähernd das ist eben ging vor
allem das wirtschaftliche gleichwohl
haben ostdeutsche damals auch die sind
jetzt nicht alle überfallen worden bei
der bei der Wahl und ihm wurde gezwungen
praktisch CDU zu wählen sie haben selber
auch CDU gewählt sie haben praktisch
selber auch diesen Kurs gewählt und auch
immer weiter gewählt obwohl eigentlich
ja dann durchaus auch abgezeichnet hat
in welche Richtung ist eben gibt es die
blühende Landschaften jetzt doch
irgendwie auf sich warten lassen also
ich würde beides sehen dass es natürlich
eine differ also Probleme gab eben nach
der Wiedervereinigung wie die passiert
ist aber trotzdem würde ich gerne die
Leute nie außer Verantwortung auch
selber rausnehmen und ich bin nicht
westdeutsch ich bin aus Deutsch und
genau Führer aus der Perspektive heraus
die Diskussion muss man dazu sagen
selber in der Sächsischen Schweiz genau
auf dem Dorf und jetzt in Leipzig Leben
da kommt übrigens auch Herz Zahn her aus
Leipzig hallo Herr Zahn herzlich
willkommen in unserer Runde ja
wunderschönen guten Tag aus Leipzig ja
der Vorredner hat mir viele schon
weggenommen ohne AFD würden wir uns
genauso weiter vorstellen es hätte sich
wahrscheinlich kam etwas getan
meine Punkte die ich jetzt ansprechen
möchte sind auch folgende wir hatten ich
bin mit SPD-Mitglied wir hatten jetzt
160 Jahre SPD und Daten mich genossen
angesprochen auch in Leipzig
Tätigkeiten es wird nur erfunden Niveau
gemacht
das kann ich nicht verstehen lassen wir
haben
bildungsschwierigkeiten in der
Gesundheitspolitik Schwierigkeiten wenn
man um sich umschalten nur
Schwierigkeiten und teilweise sind sie
auch hausgemacht wenn ich zum Beispiel
ich begleite in der damit die Software
kommt es auf DM dort Sozialamt gehe dann
ist es so dass es sie kamen Aufklärung
bekommt was sie verrechte vom
Möglichkeiten hat Kinder z.B aus ähm
Familien haben mir auch die Möglichkeit
den ähm
tätig zu sein hat keiner weiß das keiner
weiß das und ich denke wir müssen auch
die Leute aufklären erstmal was wir
überhaupt hier vermutlichkeiten haben in
unserer Republik was es vermutlichkeiten
gibt lassen Sie Herrn Reitz in unserer
Runde gerne auf ihre Gedanken mal
antworten er hat schon aufgezeigt er
zahlen mit der Erfahrung aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen die SPD war mal die
Kamera Partei also wenn sie sagen sie
sind SPD-Mitglied im
Osten und in Leipzig dann haben Sie
jetzt gerade eine Beschreibung gegeben
für die Arbeit die die SPD da machen
sollte ja das ist richtig das heißt aber
man hat jetzt schon gemerkt dass dieses
Jammern auf hohem Niveau ist ja genau
wieder der Punkt was wir vorhin auch
schon mal angesprochen haben das Abholen
der Menschen ich würde Uwe Neuhaus aus
Dinslaken noch mal mit in die Runde
holen hallo Herr Neuhaus ja schönen
guten Tag gerne Ihre Frage ja meine
Frage geht eigentlich dahin um den
Begriff großen populistisch ist es nicht
ein Fehler Argumente der AFD als
Populismus und populistisch abgrenze und
wer es nicht sinnvoller sich dann mit
diesen Argumenten sachlich
auseinanderzusetzen und meine Frage geht
ganz speziell an den Reiz stimmt es dass
der Begriff Populismus so verwendet wird
wie er jetzt verwendet wird dadurch dass
zwei Wissenschaftler die den Begriff
Populismus eine neue Deutung gegeben
haben bereits Frage ging direkt an Sie
Populismus ist
ein schillernder Begriff von ehrlich
gesagt von dem ich nichts halte wenn ein
Argument gut ist dann macht es nichts
wenn es populär ist und wenn es gut ist
aber schlecht aber sozusagen nur eine
Strömung bedient dann kann man es auch
dann kann man das auch wieder legen was
die AFD im Bundestag beispielsweise
macht das ist nicht populistisch sondern
es ist geladen und das gibt ein
Unterschied den habe ich ja eben
versucht an am Beispiel der Erdinger
Diskussion also dieser Erdinger
Veranstaltung zu erläutern es gibt
sozusagen einen bürgerlichen Populismus
der sich bemüht um Zustimmung bei Wahlen
so und da ist halt in Bayern geht's halt
gar nicht zu und es gibt aber im
Bundestag Ebene und die morgen geladene
Debatte und wenn über die Argumente der
AFD im Bundestag beispielsweise nicht
diskutiert wird dann auch deswegen weil
die AFD selber das gar nicht will und
ähm über ihre sehr militante Sprache
sozusagen selber eine Brandmauer
hochzieht sie will gar nicht dass über
ihre Thesen noch ernsthaft diskutiert
wird und das ist eben auch eine Sache
die man die man sehen muss und das kann
ich Ihnen sagen das ist in jeder
Bundestagssitzung so
Nikolai Erdinger
falsch unterwegs sind aus Siegen ist in
unserer Runde herzlich willkommen was
möchten Sie Fragen hallo in die Runde
sie haben in der Sendung meines
Erachtens sehr innenpolitisch diskutiert
und ich frage mich ob die Stärke der AFD
nicht auch eine internationale Dimension
hat also einmal die Stärke der rechten
insgesamt SPÖ in Österreich oder Trump
und im Speziellen aber auch noch die
Frage
sehen sie eine Gefahr darin dass auch
ausländische staatliche Akteure
diese Stärke befördern indem sie zum
Beispiel Fake News Kampagnen oder
ähnliches fahren namentlich gefragt wäre
da nach Russland die Frage gerne in die
Runde Dankeschön der Edinger auch ist
tatsächlich so wir haben jetzt hier in
der Runde uns auf bestimmte Themen
fokussiert sind relativ innenpolitisch
geblieben liegt auch immer alles
bisschen am Zeitkontingent aber Frau
durch aus berechtigter Blick auch
rauszugehen aus Deutschland absolut
richtig was der Hörer sagt das hat auf
jeden Fall eine internationale Dimension
und Sicherheitsbehörden sind sich auch
sicher dass es da durchaus Unterstützung
aus Russland gibt in welcher Form genau
und in welcher Dimension da ist man sich
nicht richtig schlüssig drüber aber das
ist das gibt ist klar also es geht kann
so weit gehen dass tellonym
gruppengesteuert werden dass Inhalt ins
Feld ja auf dass gewisse
verschwörungsinhalte
jeweils adaptiert auf das jeweilige
Thema das dann gerade in ist durch
dieselben Gruppen durchgetragen werden
und auch in der enormen Geschwindigkeit
also das ist dann gewissen technischen
Support gibt und das ist auch alles Geld
kostet ist relativ klar es gibt auch die
Vermutung dass Demonstrationsgeschehen
durchaus beeinflusst wird kollegen von
mir haben neulich mal über interne
Papiere aus dem russischen Staatsapparat
berichtet da ging es auch um solche
Steuerungsmechanismen des spielte nicht
hierzulande aber das wäre natürlich
hierzulande auch denkbar auch im Blick
den man wahrscheinlich noch mal eine
ganze eigene Sendung zu machen auch
Blick auf die Wahlen in den USA im
nächsten Jahr Frank Knut in Berlin
möchte sicher sein wir freuen uns auch
gut ja folgendes ich glaube dass die AFD
total falsch von den anderen Parteien
bekämpft wird dadurch dass alle auf die
einschlagen kriegt so ein eigenes Symbol
und sagt guck mal die sind alle gegen
uns wenn man sie einfach mal dran kommen
lassen wurde zum Beispiel in Schwerin
sind jetzt da ja Wahlen möglich ich bin
kein AFD aber wenn Sie die gewinnmütze
dann müsste sie sich beweisen dann
müsste sie zeigen dass sie das anders
macht und besser macht als die anderen
ich glaube das kann sie nicht und das
wird sie auch nicht und das würde sie
entzauen und das wurde dann auch die
Enttäuschung der Wähler mit sich führen
dass sie dann auch nicht mehr diesen
Zuspruch kriegt also Dankeschön für den
Hinweis ist natürlich auch ein Gedanke
der manchmal so eine Rolle spielt lass
sie doch mal machen in Schwerin geht's
ja in die Stichwahl am kommenden Sonntag
ist wäre das nicht eine Möglichkeit
könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel nächstes
Jahr auch machen bei den anstehenden
Landtagswahlen ich glaube es hat sich
zwei Komponenten also ich würde auch
sagen z.B dass man öfter also Abgrenzung
kann auch einfach mal sein dass man auf
sich konzentriert also das Parteien sich
nicht die ganze Zeit auf die AFD
konzentrieren wie jetzt sich mal den
Peter schwarzen Peter hin schier sondern
auf ihre Stärken was ist eigentlich
unser narrativ womit wollen wir gewinnen
ich kann nur sagen ja es ist natürlich
ein Gedanke der irgendwie verlockend ist
aber wir haben erleben einfach das eben
die AFD immer stärker wird auch in den
Kommunalparlamenten und das bedeutet
einfach sehr konkret das Entscheidungen
vor Ort von diesen Akteuren getroffen
werden die nachhaltig Folgen haben und
wir haben von uns darüber geredet dass
Kommunalpolitik ja da geht es um Straßen
da geht es um Förderungen für
Jugendprojekte da geht es um
Kulturangebote und genau diese Angebote
die irgendwie vielleicht auch
alternativer sind die anders sind die
nicht dementsprechend wieder AFD sich
das vorstellt die sind bedroht im Modem
Moment wo Menschen dort in irgendwie ein
Verantwortung kommen und dann wenn wir
dann sagen gut dann sitzt man das vier
Jahre aus dann bringt das auch große
Gefahren mit sich ich würde gerne Herrn
Speck aus Berlin noch schnell mit dazu
nehmen Herr schmeckt schnelle Frage noch
von ihnen bitte ja schönen guten Tag
groß aus Berlin ich wollte nur zu der
Äußerung von Herrn Reiz äh die die in
die deutsche Mitte die Mitte wir müssen
in die Mitte in die Mitte die Mitte
heute ist eigentlich sehr weit links im
Vergleich zu anderen Strauß Zeiten wo
die Mitte sehr weit rechts war die SPD
muss ich weiter Richtung rechts
orientieren dann kriegt sie auch so ein
bisschen was von der AFD ab danke Ihnen
für diese diesen Gedanken noch hier in
unsere Runde herreiz ist ich würde sagen
dann geht die letzte Antwort an sie
das ist jedenfalls ein weit verbreiteter
Empfindung da haben Sie Recht in der SPD
wird das wird das auch diskutiert und
sie sehen im Moment bei den heftigen
Diskussionen die es bei den Grünen hat
um die Frage wie stehen wir zu diesem
europäischen
Asylrecht da wird das ja auch wieder
deutlich es geht aber im Grunde genommen
weniger um die Frage von rechts oder
links sondern um die Frage von
Regierungsfähigkeit und Verantwortung
und da sind die Linien die man die man
eigentlich ziehen muss und da ist auch
die Grenze zu AFD
ist das so Frau Riedel zwischen
regierungsfähigkeiten Verantwortung ja
also die AFD ist nicht regierungsfähig
meines Erachtens weil sie es eben auch
gar nicht wirklich ernsthaft sein möchte
und weil sie auch nicht damit rechnet
ist zu sein sie hat das Personal nicht
und sie hat nicht die Ideen sie hat
nicht die Themen und es wäre inhaltlich
auch nicht wünschenswert bei vielen sie
steht in Verdacht gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung systematisch
zu verstoßen gegen die Menschenwürde und
gegen das Demokratieprinzip das möchte
ich mir nicht in Regierungsverantwortung
vorstellen was interessant ist ist dass
wir nicht nur über Themen Inhalte
sprechen sondern eben auch um über die
Gruppe sprechen müssen wenn wen gilt es
überhaupt anzusprechen ich danke Ihnen
für diese Runde für den Presseclub
nachgefragt und natürlich vielen Dank
auch an sie für ihre Meinung und ihre
Fragen an unsere Hunde das war's von uns
für diesen Sonntag bis ganz bald haben
sie noch ein schönes Wochenende
[Musik]